all right helena
hello helena where'd you grow up where
are you from originally
uh originally from norway was that right
yeah
and you moved to the united states what
age
oh my god now you're gonna have to make
me might make me do math uh uh
age i moved here in 97 so that may be
about
23. okay yeah so you grew up in
norway yeah born and raised how was your
childhood uh i good
normal childhood mom and dad yep
uh no siblings only child
um
but yeah i did all my schooling there
and um
had some jobs and then i kind of i i
came over to la on vacation in 94.
uh kind of got head hunted by some
talent manager and they're like you have
to come to l.a we'll help you out and
ever since then you know i've i've been
here
and you've been married have kids
uh i was married that
uh resolved so to speak in
2004
no kids no kids
and you have an interesting
fascination with
something that affects your personal
life right yes
how would you describe it
uh
well um um
obviously the the term bdsm is very
broad but you know i'm into
um
most people call it more of a niche
because it's very
uh
there's a lot of people into it
uh but it's a little controversial and
you know it's called
more edge play than anything but it's
it's a medical fetish
um but it goes way beyond you know just
using a speculum and and
having you know some sexual fun
uh you know for me it's about you know
the
authenticity of it and it has to or it
doesn't have to be but it needs to be
really authentic
real
medical stuff we're talking the
instruments and the you know whether
it's a gyno chair or a surgery table or
whatever it is
um i've
what i consider i've been fortunate
enough to play with real medical
professionals
and you know obviously you get the real
genuine
you know experience
and i don't know what it is but that is
just something that's always it's been
there since i was about
12
and um
it's something that's really deeply
rooted kind of
i i i feel like i just it's it's a need
it's a real need is it hard for you to
be satisfied
sexually with without that in play um
yes and no i mean you know not to say
that i can't have you know regular
vanilla sex and not be satisfied but i i
i can't be in a a long-term committed
relationship with any
form of medical play
because it is so
um
[Music]
i crave it if i don't get it for a long
period of time so you need a
relationship where that's yeah i i do
and then it's just a very strange
feeling and you know it narrows down the
pool of people that you can date which
makes it really hard
and personally i've been searching for
i don't know about a decade
to find that right person because
you know a lot of if you want to go into
you know uh
having a relationship with a real
medical professional
a lot of them you know are afraid of you
know potentially losing their license or
you know maybe get cold feet because
they think that you might out them in
some shape or form they want you to sign
ndas which i don't have a problem with
because i'm not out to wreck anybody's
you know um
career
um but yeah it
it makes it a little hard when you go to
find somebody who's into it as well yeah
but who can deliver
yeah exactly yeah and you don't you
can't just go on match and meet somebody
and say hey by the way i'm into this you
know you probably see the person run off
as fast as they can and just to have
somebody put on a doctor's
outfit and a speculum doesn't really do
the trick no it doesn't it doesn't you
know i've had a lot of people approach
me on you know i have my
my twitter following and then you know
fetlife and i've had people that you
know they're they're into also medical
play but for them
it's sufficient to like what you're
saying just put on yeah the pretend you
know pretend to do the syringe pretend
to do the iv pretend to do the procedure
but to me it's like no no no if you're
gonna do the iv
i want the iv in
but i want it done by somebody who knows
what they're doing because safety i mean
no matter what you do in in you know
bdsm to me safety comes first you
actually you and i had an appointment to
meet yesterday but you missed it because
you were actually
tell me why you missed yesterday's
yeah that was that that wasn't so much
fun uh that was an actual medical
procedure but uh
yeah that was uh about 30 vials plus of
blood draw
and and the weird thing is and some
people are a little surprised when i say
it others get it
but i
i can separate
you know if i go to the doctor if i go
to the gynecologist and i have my pap
smear or something you know i don't get
sexually aroused
now of course if i let my mind wander
and i go into that space i might
but to me it's just
that that's a doctor's appointment and i
keep that like professional so i don't
you know go into my my play space so i
can separate that so
you know yesterday having my blood drawn
and whatnot that was just that's just a
medical procedure
it's not yeah there's nothing sexual to
me about that
and and where do you think this came
from
um
my best guess is
probably because my dad used to work in
uh or for a medical supply company
and so they would supply you know
hospitals doctors offices with
you know instruments uh
i don't know if you want to call it
furniture but the the the various
implements that they needed whether it's
you know operating table
exam table
gyno chair all those things you know so
and at the time i was i had a horse and
my my parents got me the horse when i
was
very young and the stipulation was you
have to pay its board and it's upkeep
and all that so
what happened was i was doing cleaning
where my dad worked
so i got to spend a lot of time there
and nobody else around you and i got to
see all these things and kind of up
close and i was like wondering you know
what's this what's that because you're
12 you know and at that point even
though you're slowly starting to get
or maybe understanding what's
you know uh the sexual part of you is
i didn't connect the dots
it was just i had this intense
um
[Music]
fascination with it you know
and um
it was probably about a couple years
later that i started
kind of toying with you know um i
remember my parents had this kit with
like a
you know body
and stuff and i would use it like you
know you use like a sexual wand or
use cling wrap to mummify myself you
know and
i don't know where it came from but it
was like that was arousing to me and i
thought well you know i got to be nuts
you know there's something wrong with me
you know i would kind of and i would
think about medical things as i was
doing it and that would make it even
more enticing
so it kind of grew from there
and then i just you know i didn't really
do much with it for for a long time
until
um
i was probably in my mid-20s
um when i kind of started
really thinking about it again and
thinking well
i gotta figure this thing out like you
know what what is with this you know
and um i can't remember what prompted me
to go online or or what to look for but
i came across you know some some medical
videos
and um
it just really kind of spoke to me i'm
like that's it you know that's
like that's i i want to try that
and then you go through the face of like
you get cold feet you're like i can't do
it and you go back and forth and you
feel weird and you feel like something's
wrong with you
and then you get to the phase well how
do i put this into
real life like how do i find somebody
who's actually into this
that i can be comfortable enough to
explore this with
and um
you know
luckily for me
um
i managed to find a real
medical professional a surgeon
was my first experience
uh he had a huge
clinic
uh
in torrance
and so uh you know we played in his
uh or and like the the after care rooms
and it was just
it was like a revelation you know
because he did
i mean i had never experienced any of
this before i just seen it you know but
you know he would use the ivs and the
oxygen and gas and do different
procedures and
you know it
it just it was so
mind-blowing
and at that point
it was like this
light bulb and it was like that's it
you know like i found my place and
i need this i just get chilled right now
just thinking about it you know it's
like
and because
i mean it's not just the feeling of it
but for me it's also the the smell
seeing the the equipment and
like the sound of
steel and the feeling of the cold steel
um but also
the immense amount of trust
that you have to have with a partner
when you're dealing with edge play like
that because
if they sedate you
and they have you restrained
where are you going to go how are you
going to get out
so you have to have complete trust and
comfort you know in that person
and that's what makes it really intimate
i think it's actually one of the most
intimate forms of
bdsm
because of that
you know
um
and i just it's very it's very
intriguing to me
and you you prefer the role of patient
uh yeah i do uh so you know i consider
myself a sub in that sense but i can
switch so i have you know played the
doctor and been dominant
but of course there are things when it
comes to medical stuff that you know i
just cannot do because i'm not trained
to do so and i'm not going to attempt to
put in a catheter
in somebody if i'm not trained because
it's not safe
do you think there was something in your
childhood that you experienced that
maybe
created this or is it just the fact that
your father
worked in that field and had the devices
around maybe you saw them or you went to
his work one day or something like that
yeah i i don't remember because i i
as a child i was never
i was never sick so i never went to the
hospital or the doctor or anything like
that so i ca i can't say it stems from
anything like that
so that's the only thing that i
concluded is that i was just exposed to
that environment
and for whatever reason it just it
resonated with me
and i to this day after
spending endless hours of trying to
figure out
why
that's the only thing i can think of
is that i just i had that not daily but
constant exposure to it
and it just
i don't know it just did something to me
you know it's not like you know some
people probably walk past a
you know a
surgery table and they just look at it
and you know they walk on and
don't notice but to me it's like oh you
know i can think of like
all kinds of things i can do on there
you know i assume the most powerful
sexual experiences you've had have been
in this
area yes
so once you've experienced that then
everything else pales in comparison it
does yeah and i can't say i'm only into
that because i do
really enjoy um latex heavy rubber and
that kind of thing too but
medical play is definitely like my deep
deep passion
so you know at times where i can combine
everything
even better
you know but um that's definitely when
somebody asked me you know what i'm
mainly into
that's it you know i've you know i'm in
the process of
getting my site up it'll probably be up
in a day or two um
i mean it's it's such a
a niche that
um
i mean i've had interviews several
interviews and a lot of the you know big
time
magazines
the real magazines that are left still
not just online
uh overseas even in in the us because
they're so intrigued by it because it's
you know it's
most people are into you know i mean
there's
a lot of people obviously into bdsm but
it's like you think of it and you think
about restraints and spanking and caning
and maybe hoods and masks and
although i'm into hoods and masks i'm
not into the spanking and whatnot but
that's kind of like the
mainstream you know so to speak
and so when you tell them that you're
really into the authentic
you know medical play and and actually
what goes on
everybody is very intrigued by that
you know and i was amazed when i opened
my twitter account and i started posting
my photos and
i was up to you know 6 000 some
followers and
like
a blink you know because people were
like is this real is this really you
like are you really under
i'm like yeah
do you think there's a larger part of
our population that's into this kind of
stuff
i think there's a lot more than you
think yeah
i think a lot of people either a they
haven't tried it but they really really
want to
or they've tried it but it's really hard
to find
you know somebody that's
willing to do it a good practice or can
do it yeah
yeah
and you're not hurting anybody
no no i will not i do uh live sessions
you know um
and
the first thing i always tell
people because some people get a little
worried like why i don't want this i
don't you know i don't want that and i'm
like you know what you're safe i always
send out a what i call the bdsm list
where they list their hard limits
what they've experienced before what
they haven't experienced so i know
exactly what they've done what they
haven't done what they're open to
what they don't want to do and i'm like
your safety is number one
and know this i will never ever exceed
your limits and if you're ever
uncomfortable or you're scared
just say stop
and it will stop
because i've been in that position
myself where i almost got out of it
because i got so scared once
and it's not a good feeling and you want
to know that you're
you know you're comfortable and safe
with the person that you're playing with
whether it's medical play or anything
else but is there an element of danger
to it all
yeah maybe going to a doctor is
sometimes scary for people yeah yeah um
i mean for me it's not really i don't
have any fear
but it's the um
of course the anticipation
because you don't unless you really i
don't like to do it really like scripted
because then you it loses that
anticipation
because i don't like to know what's
coming next you know and so my life is
there's a respect factor as well right
you're oh yeah you're respecting your
practitioners you have to really there's
got to be respect
without that i don't want to play with
somebody you know and
um
you know my last partner you would
literally put me under you know
anesthesia
and
you got to trust somebody with your life
you know and and be completely
comfortable to
let somebody do that you know
um
[Music]
and but yeah there is a risk factor to
that but it's just like you know if you
go and you have surgery there's a risk
to that too
and some people may say well you know
you're stupid for doing that because
what if
well yeah i realized that but
you know we do the
take the precautions you know that
we feel are necessary it's all being
monitored you know blood pressure your
heart rate your
your
oxygen saturation everything you know um
without that i wouldn't do it
sometimes the tolerance of risk is what
brings about the reward that
we really want yeah yeah and a lot of
people are just not willing to risk
take take those risks so that you know
they'll never see the
pleasure or whatever you want to call it
that we're talking about here yeah yeah
no it's definitely i i can understand
how some people are
um
you know a little reluctant to do it you
have to be adventurous yeah yeah you do
you know it's not for the faint of heart
that's for sure
and is it
so
it's it's satisfying it's it's something
you long for it's it's hard to find
which makes it even more
tantalizing when you finally get it i'm
sure
yes yeah that's part of the magic of it
right yeah yeah
i i
my last partner you know i was lucky
enough that we you know i got to have it
several times a week sometimes every day
and um
i can safely say i probably could do it
every day if i if i had the opportunity
but when long periods go by like now
you know you start to get that itch
and you're like wow you know what can i
do because
without that partner with that
experience you have to go to a lot of
people i can't i can't do anything you
have to go to a lot of medical
conventions right yeah
i have to go to medical school
yeah yeah
and does it is that you're professional
you have a job outside of this yeah but
this is also something you do
professionally
the medical no just like working with
with clients that are into this yes yes
yeah i have people that um
my followers if you want to call it that
fans
that approach me about um
having live sessions
and i just had a guy he signed up for a
24-hour
session
now of course you can't play
continuously for 24 hours that's
impossible
you know and he knows that but you know
some people too they just you know if
you put them in bondage just restrain
them on the operating table and and hook
them up to you know the ekg and
uh you know blood pressure and things
like that you know and you leave them
for a few hours um you know they're
perfectly content with that because they
just
you know they slip into you know what we
call like the subspace
where they just
you know it's
it's a weird thing because it's for me
it's very relaxing it's it's therapeutic
it's
it takes away
um i mean i'm speaking just for myself
here but it takes away the stress and
thoughts of the outside world
because you're just in that space
and
doing what you love
and you don't think about anything else
and you just slip into that space
and it just it gives you a very
it's it's very
yeah it's
there's a lot of satisfaction to it
and does it does your appetite for
more extreme experiences grow as as you
as you have new experiences i mean
um
yes and no i mean i've i've your
examinations get wilder and wilder i
guess
well
with the medical
you know there's only
so far you can go i mean some people you
know obviously
they're into cutting
suturing
you know actual surgeries and things
like that
that i don't do i don't do anything that
leaves permanent marks and and blood
that's just not worth it to me i'm and
that's where i draw this there are some
people that are into that yeah oh yeah
very much
um
and they do and you know they do body
modifications
i've had doctors approach me and asked
if you know can i modify you to look
like a doll you know which means breast
augmentation
you know you name it and i'm like that's
just a little too much for me that's not
play anymore that then it becomes
a little too extreme
you know for me it's just the experience
of certain
i mean they may be invasive procedures
but i would never go to the extent of
being cut and sutured and having
surgeries and things like that
but you know i do um you know my
appetite can grow for okay i like
hoods more or i like you know um
[Music]
latex more in play or
you know certain elements that i i kind
of incorporate so
you know you try different things
as you go along and you realize well you
know i like this i don't like this and i
mean it's it's it's really never ending
and it's only
restricted by your own
imagination that's what's so great about
bdsm you know it's like there's no limit
as to
how far you can go or what you can do
um it's only limited by what you can
think of
you know so and it sounds like
authenticity and respect are the
the uh
the things that kind of control the most
to make it most most satisfying for you
right yeah and then and obviously having
the comfort with the person that you're
playing with you have to be 100
comfortable otherwise you cannot
you can't let go
and that's the whole idea is for you to
be able to just fully let go and is your
encounters are they basically just an
examination or they do they culminate in
a sexual
um
it kind of depends on who i play with
if it's just you know a person that i i
occasionally play with
um it may just be play um but no
intercourse
um just because i want to be you know
you got to be careful with
you know who you have sex with and
whatnot but um
so yeah i'd say that it kind of varies
it depends it depends on if it's
somebody that i'm comfortable enough
with and i know enough about
uh if it's somebody that i've played
with a few times and i know that person
then yeah sex can happen
um but it's not
necessarily
a requirement on either end
to
to have sex you know it's the play that
kind of gets you off if you will
and the medical fetish
is is just one of many
of course right yes there's there's a
whole oh gosh it's pages upon pages so
subculture after subculture of yeah
people that are into this that and the
other yeah
what does that say about our society
you know
it
it's funny because you know the medical
association in their
uh what's it called
uh international
it's the idc you know the different
codes for
diseases
bdsm used to be
in there as a psychiatric disease like
you're mentally ill if you're into any
of this
now they remove that
um which i think it's good because
most of us have it yeah yeah i mean sure
i'm sure there are crazy people in in
that field as well just like there is uh
you know anywhere else but
most the people that i've encountered
that are into any of this are actually
some of the nicest people i know
and i think it's
um you're saying about society
i think people that are into some form
of
bondage slash bdsm
have a much healthier
sex life
and
um
they're more grounded
i mean i know that sounds very strange
um
but i think because you have an outlet
that's right that's right you know not
just a sexual outlet
but it's also
it's a creative outlet it's um
bondage it's bonding
you know it bonds people
um yeah i can imagine someone being very
frustrated with their life yeah
if if they never get to express these
hidden desires that they they have and
they can't express because they have the
right partner or they don't have the
courage to take that risk or their
they're just unable to connect with
somebody that can yeah help them yeah i
i think you know if you have one one
person
who's uh interested in it or into it and
then the other partner is not
you're gonna have you know uh
relationship issues
and i've been there because i've had you
know straight uh vanilla relationships
and it's it's frustrating you know
because i feel like i can't
i can't be my true self
and that's why you know it's taken
so long to try to find somebody because
i know if i go into
a vanilla relationship
initially it may be just fine and it's
exciting it's new but eventually
i'm gonna have that need and if that
partner can't give me that
you know what i need it's gonna cause
issues
you know so
yeah i think a lot of people
um
either aren't aware of
you know their um
sexual needs maybe they don't understand
like if they're not sexually satisfied
with a partner they may not know
that they in fact
might be into it
until maybe they get exposed to it and
try it and they go oh that was kind of
like the missing link for me
you know and and that's what happened
for me
because even though i enjoy regular sex
it was like i feel like something is
missing
there's something i just i'm not like
100
satisfied you know but once i found this
and i really started
delving into it i'm like oh
yeah there we have it you know so if i
can mix the two
you know that would be the the perfect
world
yeah all right elena thank you so much
for sharing your story thank you very
interesting thanks thank you very much
you